[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم تناولت مع ضيفي في الحلقه
الماضيه الدكتور سعد البازعي الناقد
والمفكر السعودي قضيه الحداثه في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وحكايتها المثيره في
الثمانينات الميلاديه والصراع الذي نشا
حول موضوعها واتجاهاتها وترك اثره الكبير
على المجتمع السعودي بين مؤيد او متحفظ
والحقيقه ان انشغالات البازعي لا تنحصر في
المجتمع المحلي فقط وان كانت اكثر تركيزا
بحكم انتمائه لكن الرجل انشغل بما هو اوسع
من ذلك اتضح في ترجمته المشتركه لكتاب
الاخلاق في عصر الحداثه السائله
وسلسله كتبه الاخرى معالم الحداثه الحداثه
الغربيه في 60 نصا تاسيسيا من القرن
السابع عشر حتى العشرين وكذلك استقبال
الاخر الغرب في النقد العربي الحديث وكتاب
الاختلاف الثقافي وثقافه الاختلاف فضلا عن
انشغاله بقضايا بالغه الاهميه في كتب
مكون اليهودي في الحضاره الغربيه وترجمته
لكتاب المسلمون في التاريخ الامريكي ارث
منسي وقد كان البازعي على الدوام مشتبكا
مع كافه القضايا المتفرعه عن فكره الحداثه
ومجالها فتجده يؤرخ لمفهوم النسويه وينشغل
بمفهوم المعرفه ويتابع كذلك هجره المفاهيم
كما يصفها وهو على الدوام يتخذ موقف
القارئ والمتفحص الموضوعي غير المنخرط
ايدولوجيا في صراعات الحداثه المتشعبه معه
اناقش الليله جل هذه القضايا التي تشغل
الساحه العربيه وتحوز على اهتمام مثقفيها
وشبابها وناشطها ونخبتها الدكتور سعد
البازعي الناقد والمفكر السعودي ضيف
الحلقه هذا المساء فاهلا ومرحبا بكم
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بك يا دكتور كانت اطروحتك للدكتوراه
الاستشراق في الاداب الاوروبيه تخصصك اصلا
في الادب الانجليزي كان لافتا في تلك
الفتره يبدو مغايرا لما اعتاد عليه الشباب
في تخصصاته العلميه كان شيء ببالك او كانت
المساله ارتباط باللغه بالادب بشكل او
باخر لا هو ارتباط منذ الصغر بالاداب
الاجنبيه يعني تعرضت لبعض المؤثرات اثناء
القراءه اذكرني قرات في مجله العربي
بالمناسبه ترجمات للشاعر اجنبي وظل في
ذهني هذا الكلام ثم قرات لدى بعض المؤلفين
العرب كيف اثرت الاداب الاوروبيه في تطور
الادب العربي الى اخره فظل هذا الموضوع في
ذهني عندما كان علي ان اتخصص كان امامي
اما قسم باللغه العربيه او الانجليزيه
واقنعت نفسي واقنعني لحتى منهم حول ذاك
الوقت ان اللغه العربيه بامكانك ان تقراها
في اي وقت لكن الانجليزيه تحتاج الى ان
تتعلمها لان لغه اجنبيه وادبها صعب والى
اخره فكان هذا حافز لان ادرس الاداب
الاجنبيه
ومع الزمن تعمق الموضوع
ولكني ايضا ظليت على ارتباط قوي بالادب
العربي وكانني كنت اشعر بالذنب نعم نشاطك
الثقافي مرتكز حول الادب حتى اثناء وجود
في البعثه انا اذكر اني كنت اذهب الى
جامعه قريبه واستعير كتب ودواوين شعر
البحتري والمتنبي والاخره
ويعني اتابع واقرا بحيث ان لا تنقطع صلتي
بالادب العربي وا حسين وكذا
اطروحه تاثرت بدوره سعيد قابلته هناك لقاء
سريع
الحقيقه اثناء اهتمامي بالاستشراق يعني ما
كان ما كانت تروح على الاستشراق بهذا
المعنى كانت دراسه
التصورات الغربيه للعرب والمسلمين في
الاداب كيف انعكست في الاداب الاوروبيه
وهذا يشكل هاجس على تجد هنا مثلا بدوي هنا
تجد تاجر يعني شخصيات مختلفه في الروايات
في المسرحيات عطيل مثلا شخصيه مغربيه يعني
في هذا الامر فعندما
ظهر كتاب الدور سعيد ثمانيه دراستك باربعه
وسبعين ثمانيه بالضبط يعني دخلت المرحله
الدكتوراه يعني في هذه المرحله في هذا
الوقت
فنبهني احد الاساتذه لانه كتابه جديدا ظهر
لادوار سعيد بعنوان والاستشراق
فقرات الكتاب واثر في راسا يعني لانه
اعطاني
الاساس النظري للدراسه بحيث انها اخذت بعد
الاستشراق فعنونه سالب الاستشراق الادبي
وتبنيت الجهاز النظري الذي وضفه الدور
سعيد وطبعا من ادوارد سعيد ميشيل فوكول
الفيلسوف الفرنسي الفرنسي
كانت العلاقه يعني قويه ادوار سعيد قابلته
في مؤتمر سريع يعني كان كان مشغول حقيقه
نجم المرحله كان نجم الاوساط الامريكيه
كلهم حوله فاعطاني دقيقتين يمكن سالني
ماذا تريد
اخبرته بعدين قال لي استاذي المشرف انت
لست بحاجه الى الرجل يعني شخصيا كتبه
موجوده فالكتاب هو المهم بماذا اثر عليك
الاستشراق لادوار سعيد في
موقفك الاساسي من فهم الغرب وفمه فهم
الغرب تجاهها ايضا ثقافتنا العربي نعم انا
اعتقد انه يعني الدور الذي ينبغي ان يقوم
به امثالي من دارسي الاداب الاجنبيه
والثقافات الاجنبيه هو تسليط الضوء على
الحضاره الغربيه والتعريف التعريف بها
والدراستها في عمقها وليس فقط التاثر بها
والاستفاده منها يعني هناك فرق بين ان
تستفيد من حضاره الاخر وان تفهم الاخر
يعني الاستفاده ان تاتي الادوات تاخذ
نظرياتي الفلسفات لكن ايضا ان تفهم الجذور
كيف تطورت
ما هي مشكلاتها ما هي انجازات وهذا كله
هذه كلها يعني يستطيع ان ينهض بها من هو
متخصص وهذا بالضبط اللي سواه دور سعيد
يعني في دراساته الاداب الاوروبيه الغربيه
بصفه عامه لم تنتج فقط عن الاستشراق لو
كتب اخرى
تدرس هذه الحضاره في عمقها في في في
تكوينها الاساسي وهذا الذي حاولت ان انتدب
نفسي له بعد الكتاب بعد الاطروحه يعني
فاستمرت في دراسات مختلفه يعني من يطلع
على كتب مثل قلق المعرفه مثلا او الاختلاف
الثقافي او المكون اليهودي يجد امتداد
لاطروحه الدكتوراه لانها تسير على نفس
التفسير في نفس الاتجاه الذي هو
معرفه الاخر وكلمه الاخر تتكرر في عناوين
كتبي بالمناسبه كثيرا يعني عندي اكثر من
كتاب عنوانه الاخر وطبعا جاءت يعني كانك
مهجوس بهذا المكون الرئيسي الغربي طيب
امام الغرب احنا دائما دكتور امام موقفين
السائدين في الساحه العربيه موقف
منضوي تماما مندمج تماما سائح تماما في
هذه في الغربيه لها سياده والهيمنه
والافضليه ويجب ان نسير بهذا الطريق وهو
موقف ايضا اخر على النقيض متصادم مشكك
يشعر بقلق دائم وناقد انت اين كنت بين
هذين
اعتقد انني مزيج من الاثنين
واحاول قدر الامكان ان لا
اغرق في اي منهما
لموقف ناقد من الحضاره الغربيه ولكنه موقف
ايضا
يرى او يحاول ان يستشعر ويدرك القيمه
الكبرى التي تمثلها هذه الحضاره وانها هي
الحضاره العالميه اليوم يعني هي المهمه في
العالم ولا نستطيع ان نتجاهل هذا لكن ايضا
كونها هي المهيمنه لا ينبغي ان يعني
انه لا هنا ليس هناك امكانيات لاختلاء
الاختلاف معها وانتاج سياقات او نماذج
حضاريه مختلفه
فهذا الذي فعلته عندما مثلا صدر كتاب
المكون اليهودي قيل انني امدح اليهود
وكانك
حاطه في الترتيب انه كانك نظرت لاسهامات
اليهود في الحضاره الغربيه الحديثه نظره
ايجابيه بالضبط يعني هذا نتيجه محاولتي ان
اقف في منطقه
اكثر عقلانيه وحياديه قدر الامكان في اول
الكتابه انا ذكرت عباره يعني اعتقد انها
تمثل هذا الاتجاه انه ليس اصعب من ان نكتب
عن من نحبهم وعم من نكرههم
في كلتا الحالتين نحن معرضون للتحيز
والان لا نرى الواقع كما هو
عندما تكون محاطا بالاستريو تايب بالصور
النمطيه اليهودي يعني نحن الاحسان سوره
تبين اسهامات اليهود في في المؤامرات في
الماسونيه في كذا لكن ان ياتي مثقف سعودي
ويكتب عن اسهامات مثقفين وشعراء وادباء
بارزين يهود في الحضارات الغربيه قد يبدو
الامر محل مستغرب يعني لانه
نظريه المؤامره انتهت بالنسبه لي ليست
موجوده اصلا ولا اؤمن بها
ولذلك نحن بطالبون بان نقرا فرويد وماركس
وسبينوزا وغيرهم من الكتاب ومن المحاكم
الثقه في اليهود دكتور في الحضاره ضخم جدا
يعني اعتقد انه
يعني مؤسسين اعتبرهم مؤسسين يعني طبعا في
عهد السبينوزا في القرن السابع عشر
كان هناك لبنه اساسيه وضعها هذا الرجل في
نقد الكتاب المقدس وبالتالي في دعم التوجه
العلماني للحضاره الغربيه لانه كان جريئا
جدا
ومغامرا في وقت كان يصعب المغامره لكن
انقطع الاسهام حتى القرن تقريبا الثامن
عشر منتصف القرن الثامن عشر بعدما نابليون
فتح لقيته اليهوديه
فدخل اليهود في المجتمعات الغربيه وصاروا
جزء من النسيج الاجتماعي والثقافي الغربي
ففي ذلك الحين بداوا يتحولوا الى علمائهم
مفكرين وفلاسفه بدل ما كانوا يعني مجرد
حاخامات يقراون الكتاب المقدس او جهله
يعني
صرافين احنا عندنا
يعني بالنسبه للقرن الثامن عشر تبدا بموسى
مندل زون يعتبر الفلاسفه الاوائل يعني
بالنسبه الاوروبيين اليهود الاوروبيين
والماني لكن في القرن التاسع عشر يبدا
الفيض يبدا يعني
ثم ناسيه الى فرويد ومجموعه كبيره من
العلماء
مؤسسه نعم يعني علم الاجتماع الحديث
فانت لا تستطيع ان تتجاهل هذه الاسماء
وايضا لماذا اتجهت الى علم الاجتماع
والنفس لماذا
لانه هم اقليه
واقليه تخشى الاضطهاد دائما قلقه من
الاضطهاد فتريد ان تفهم بشكل اكبر هم هذا
المجتمع هل كانوا ينظرونا وينتجون كيهود
ام كاروبيين بالدرجه الاولى كاوروبيين لكن
العنصر اليهودي وهذا اطروحه الكتاب كان
مؤثرا يعني الانتماء اليهودي اسميه
الانتماء الانتماء الاثني للجماعه
اليهوديه لا يستطيع لم يستطع اولئك ان
ينفكوا عن كونهم يهودا يعني فرويد مثلا
كان اوروبيا نمساويا لكن جاءت النازيه
واشعرته انه يهودي فهرب الى بريطانيا ومات
فيها يعني انت تاتي ياتي نظام سياسي غاشم
مثل نظام النازي ويحتل اوروبا يعيد الناس
يذكرهم بانكم ومرفوضين في نهايه الامر لكن
في الاسهامات النظريه بشكل كبير في
المجالات هل كانت ثمه اثر اليهوديتهم
لتطلعاتهم لانه احنا نربطها بما هو لاحق
انا اعتقد ان ان الاسهام جاء في نوع
الاهتمامات
الاجتماع بالضبط
نظريه نفسها يعني
فرويد له عباره في احدى رسائلي يقول لو لم
اكن يهوديا لم اهتممت بالله وعي لانني
بحاجه الى ان افهم الله وعي لهذا المجتمع
المحيط به
فاللاوعي يحرك هذه المجتمعات فانت تريد ان
تفهم كيف
ساهمت فيه بالضبط
يعني هذا طبعا اطروحه دافعت عنها امام
المرحوم الدكتور المسيري لانه راي مخالف
تماما مخالف تماما هو يرى انه لا علاقه
يهوديتهم بمنتجهم الفكري
انا اقول طيب يعني انا اعتز بالرشت
وبنسينا الم يكن كونهم مسلمين او عربا
الاثر على منتجهم يعني لم يكونوا يعني
كائنات الهواء كانوا لهم انتماء اتباع
اجتماعي وثقافي وديني اثر في منتجهم اليوم
الحداثه في موقع
اكثر صعوبه ما كانت عليه في السابق يعني
في السابق كانت كانت مشروعا مهيمنا جاذبا
مشروعا رساليا لديه اتباعه اليوم الشكوك
كثيره حول هذا الامر
شكوك حول
الحداثه يعني اعتقد ان الحداثه الان صارت
جزء من النسيج الثقافي لم تعد
الانكليات التي خلقتها اصبح النقاش حولها
بشكل اكبر مساله الاخلاق مساله التحديات
التي تطرحها كلها اصبحت مسائل رئيسيه
اليوم صحيح لكن هناك ايضا تغيرات يعني
الثقافه العربيه تتاثر
بالعالم المحيط بها والعالم المحيط بها
دخل في مرحله سمع ما بعد الحدث ما بعد
الحداثه هذه مرحله سماها
المفكر البولندي بوما الحدث السائله اللي
ترجمته الكتاب اخلاق ما بعد بالضبط
الحداثه السائله السائله
تفرق بين الحداثه الحداثه وحداثه صلبه
الحداث الصلبه اللي هي تقريبا حدثتنا الى
حد ما يعني الحداثه التي تؤمن بالمؤسسات
تؤمن بالتغيير تؤمن في مبادئ خلنا نبسط
احنا في المقابله مشروعنا
جسر
وحمزه وصل
وش الحداثه بالضبط الحداثه ان تكون حديثا
طبعا التعريف الحداثه مشكله كبيره يعني
لانه تعريفات كثيره لكن هيبه ابسط بابسط
مع نهايه للتجديد لما هو
مخالف للتقاليد القديم للماضي ونقله الى
عصر
الحاضر الى اي درجه طبعا في حالات متطرفه
تقول قطيعه مع الماضي وفي حالات لا ترى
التصالح مع الماضي والاستفاده منه انا لا
اعتقد ان هناك حداثه استطعت تنفصل على
الماضي اصلا يعني في امتداد لكنها تنتقي
من الماضي ما يناسبها يعني مثلا لو عدنا
لو ذهبنا الى اشهر الحداثيه العرب اليوم
في على مستوى الادبي اللي هو ادونيس
ادونيس من اكثر الذين عونوا بالتراث
العربي يعني موسوعه له مختارات من الشعر
العربي ومختارات من النثر العربي له عنايه
بالتراث الصوفي العربي الى اخره
لكن انتقائيه بالضبط فهو يذهب الى
تراث معين
بالضبط معنا بنقول الشاذ الاستثناء يعني
هناك من يرى انه هذا هو هذه حالات لا يقاس
عليها وان الماضي
مختلف عن هذا الذي اختاره هذا الشاعر او
ذاك فاعتقد انه الحداثه في نهايه الامر هي
الرغبه في الاختلاف والمغايره والانتقال
الى الجديد كتاب زكمه باونت اللي ترجمته
دكتور بالاشتراك طبعا مع مترجم اخرى واراء
كثيره اليوم تعزز اراء انغلاقيين يعتقدون
بانه ان الحداثه تواجه ازمه وانه ايضا
المجتمعات الغربيه اليوم ما عادت يعني ما
عادت حداثيه كما يجب اصبحت يمنيه متطرفه
منغلقه تخشى الاخر وما الى ذلك
الحداثه الغربيه الان كما يرى باؤما وغيره
يعني انها فقدت صلتها بقيم التنوير
التنوير الذي كان نقله في تاريخ الحضاره
الغربيه
التنوير الذي ولدت بمقتضاه الدوله بمفهومه
الحديث
ولدت ولدت بمقتضاه مفاهيم اساسيه
مثل حريه
والحقيقه والعداله وهذه المفاهيم التي
تغير او تطورت في ظل التنوير والعقلانيه
طبعا اهميه العقل في فتره الحديثه التي
بدات بالحرب العالميه الثانيه بعد الحرب
العالميه الثانيه حدث تحول في تاريخ
الحضاره الغربيه
فقدت بعض هذه القيم
قيمتها او صارت مشكوك بها يعني صار مثلا
لما تقول حقيقه يضحكون يعني اقول لك
الحقيقه هناك مساله نسبيه كل له حقيقته كل
يرى العالم من زاويته
فتشظت الحقيقه
امثال بوما يرى ان هذه كارثه اننا اذا
فقدنا هذه القيم الاساسيه فنحن في عالم
هولامي ندخل في عالم لا مرجعيات له لا
مرجعيه ولا ثابت في اطلاق بالضبط يعني
وهذا طبعا كلام تقوله حنا ارنت يعني
المفكره الالمانيه المعروفه وهي يهوديه
ايضا تقول انه مفهوم المرجعيه انتهى في
العصر الحديث المرجعيه لاثورتي يعني ان
يكون هناك شخص تقبل كلامه بدون نقاش لم
يعد هناك احد في الغرب يقبل كلامه بدون
نقاش لكن في ثقافات تقليديه موجوده هؤلاء
المرجعيات موجوده في من خلال الايمان
والدين والتقاليد فانت يعني نحن نعيش في
عصر حداثه تقليدي لحد ما يعني وان كانت
تركيب غريب يعني تقليدي قياسا الى ما يحدث
في مجتمعات اخرى
يعني تتقبل تغيير بشكل نحن نتحرج منه
[موسيقى]
مشروعات الدكتور سعد البازعي في التاليف
والترجمه لا تنتهي ولم يحل دونها حضوره
الواضح في وسائل التواصل او مشاركاته في
مختلف المحافل الثقافيه الخليجيه والعربيه
والدوليه او مسؤولياته الجامعيه على
كثرتها اما المجالات التي يكتب فيها
البازعي فتتنوع بين الادب والثقافه
والفلسفه عدا عن القضايا ذات الاهميه
كالحداثه بما يجعله احد اغزر الكتاب
السعوديين والعرب المعاصرين تاليفا وترجمه
في الادب نجد كتبا مثل ثقافه الصحراء
واحالات القصيده ومقاربه الاخر وفيها افرغ
البازع رؤاه النقديه المتعلقه بقضايا
ثقافيه عده وفي الفكر يسجل البازعي حضور
لافتا عبر كتب مثل قلق المعرفه وحوارات
ومكافات ومواجهات السلطه اما في الفلسفه
فقد ضرب البازع بسهم وافر عبر ترجمته
لكتابي جدل العولمه
والاخلاق في عصر الحداثه السائله الى جانب
تاليفه كتاب معالم الحداثه اما مقالات
البازع فلم تترك بابا من ابواب الثقافه
والمعرفه الا وطرقته بما يعكس هموم
الاكاديمي الناقد والمثقف المعني بقضايا
مجتمعه
[موسيقى]
قضيه النسويه اليوم اصبحت قضيه في غايه
الاهميه حتى في عالمنا العربي اصبح اصبحت
مدرسه لديها ناشطون هناك من ينظر لها
يتحدث فيها يهتم بها وهناك لبس كبير حول
حول تفاصيل انت دكتور تناولتها في في
واحده من المحاضرات من جانب التوثيقي
وتاريخي
لو استعرضنا هذه الحركه النسويه بمراحلها
بشكل بشكل سريع كيف تكون
المهتم بالجانب العربي في هي طبعا حركه
غربيه بالدرجه الاولى ظهرت في فرنسا
وتطورت في امريكا بالدرجه الاولى
وكانت في البدايه تحرير المراه
ويعني اكتساب المراه حقوقها التي
فقدتها او لم تمتلكها يوما من الايام
لكنها تحولت فيما بعد
ومع التغيرات التي حدثت بعد الحرب
العالميه الثانيه
مجيء الحداثه السائله كما يقول الى ان
تحولت الى ان المساله صارت ما يسميه
المسير الله يرحمه والتمركز الانثوي
التمركز الانثوي هو الذي يقول بان المراه
هي الاصل يعني في انقلاب تام يعني
وان النسويه هي
الايمان ان المراه هي الاساس وهي المنطلق
والانوثه هي اصل الحضاره هذا طبعا هذا جزء
من الخطاب النسوي الغربي
جاءنا بعض هذا الكلام الى الحضارتنا او
الى ثقافتنا المعاصره
فحقوق المراه لها خلاف عليها طيب وش اللي
وش الفرق الاساسي بين مساله حقوق المراه
والتي يتفق كثير من الناس معها ويقول لك
حتى بعض الناس انه هذه موجوده في الاسلام
موجوده في ثقافتنا العربيه موجوده وان
كانت يعني فيها اوجه قصور كثيره الا انه
مساله الحقوق شيء
والنقاش الاخر نعم في اخر هذه المشكله هذه
المشكله لدينا نعم تختلط الامور يعني
النسويه التي جاءتنا
نسويه تعلي من شان المراه بطريقه غير
متوازنه اجتماعيه يعني ان تقول بالتمركز
الانثوي مثلا او ان تسعى الى تغيير
الضمائر في اللغه لاحظ هذه ايضا من المؤثث
تاثيرات التي حصلت مع اجتياح الفكر النشوي
انه ينبغي تحيد الضمائر يعني ما عاد نقول
هي وهو نقول هم
يعني بالانجليزيه الان يقولون للمراه ذي
يعني هي هم
لانه لا يريدون ان يقولوا انها انثى يعني
هم مركزيه الانثى من جهه ومن جهه اخرى نعم
يعني
بالضبط في اتجاهات مختلفه هم يريدون ان
يتخلصوا من
ما علق بالضمير الانثوي من تصورات فانك ما
دمت تقول هي التخلص من الضمير الانثوي
كامله كامله وليس بالعوالق وليس صحيح فهذا
اعتقد انه يعني مما تحتاج الى معرفه لان
البعض يتعلق بهذه التغيرات والتيارات دون
ان يدرك جذورها الفلسفيه وتوجهاتها
وتيارات
تحفظي على ان بعضه عدمه توجه عدمي يعني
توجه بخل
بالثقافه كما اؤمن بها كما اراها بنيه
المجتمع
ولذلك
من يؤمن بها ينبغي ان يغير رؤيته للعالم
كلها عربيه في حركه منسويه وطبعا
يعني يمكن ان نقول عنها انا مدرسه تيار
ولا نشاط في العالم العربي رموز عامه نحن
اصداء فيك اكثر
التغيرات التي تحدث عندنا يعني نوال
السعداوي هنا مثلا فاطمه المريسي في
المغرب فلانه هنا هناك فيه اسماء مهمه
وفاعله
وناشطه ثقافيا ولهم مجلات ولهم انتاج فكري
مهم لكن من الصعب الحديث عن التيارات
بالمعنى الذي نجده في بريطانيا او فرنسا
دكتور التسويه صعبه بين مساله المزيد من
الحريات ومساله التوقف
والانتباه
لهذه الحركه او التوازن بين هذه ليس سهله
يعني نستطيع ان نقول نعم ينبغي وينبغي لكن
المساله ليست بهذا السهوله اعتقد اننا في
الاندفاع نحو
اعطاء الحقوق للمراه او للاقليات او
الفئات المختلفه في المجتمع قد
نقصر وقد نبالغ وهذا حاصل يعني
فنحن بحاجه الى
اذكاء روح النقد والحوار داخل المجتمع
لانه التغيير
والتطوير والاضافه
والتشريع بشكل عام ينبغي ان يتم ضمن
في في بيئه حواريه بيئه
تستمع للاراء لا يبدو ان هذا موجودا يعني
الى حد بشكل موضوعي حقيقه ضعيف يعني انا
كنت عضو في مجلس الشورى بالمناسبه يعني
ورايت يعني جمال الحوار اهميه ان يكون
هناك حوار حول القضايا الكبرى يعني لانه
مجلس الشورى في السعوديه فيه يعني
عدد هائل من العقول والخبرات غير العاديه
لم تنتخب لكنها انتقلت من افضل وقت
المجتمع وثقافيه فلما تطرح قضيه تستمع الى
راي الطبيب وراي المهندس وراي القانوني
وراي العسكري ورائي الاستاذ الجامعه هكذا
فالاراء يعني مدهشه هذه الاراء كنت يعني
اتمنى ان يستفاد منها بطريقه افضل لا ان
تكون مجرد يعني تعليق على قرارات او
تقارير حكوميه وما الى ذلك وفعلا المجلس
الشورى كان له دور لكن المجالس الاخرى
طبعا في الدول العربيه المختلفه لكن اعتقد
انه اقل مما هو مما ينبغي ان يكون تواجهنا
ازمه منحه اليوم ايضا من ضمن تفرعاتها
واشتقاقات الحداثه الغربيه مساله المثليه
قضيه الشذوذ الجنسيه ومسائل المثليه
الجنسيه
وهذه كحالات هي موجوده تاريخيا ومعتادا
الناس على وجودها كاستثناء وكحلات شاذه في
المجتمعات لكن اصبح الامر مختلف شاهدناها
حتى في كاس العالم الاخير في قطر وما يجب
ان القيام به واليوم الاشتراطات والامور
التي يجب ان تفرض على الدول على المؤسسات
على الافراد حتى لاعبين في انديه اوروبيه
وضع اشارات
وعمليه مواجهه منظمه من قبل المؤسسات
الغربيه لمن يقف موقفا مخالفا لهذه
المساله احنا عربيا عندنا مشكله كبيره جدا
نحن ضحيه نحن فقط نتلقى هذا الامر
ولنستطيع ان نشكل حتى موقف بمعنى هذا
الامر لا يطرح لك تدريس لا يناقش في وسائل
الاعلام لم اجد وسيله الاعلام محليه
تناقشه فكيف كيف يتعامل المثقف يعني
المثقف افترض انه هو من يستطيع ان يفكك
هذا الامر هو يفترض ان يكون من يستطيع لكن
في بيئه اكثر انفتاحا يعني تقريبا بالراي
المختلف هذه من ناحيه الناحيه الثانيه
اعتقد اننا الى حد بعيد نغفل ثلثي العالم
في هذه القضايا ننسى ان ثلثي العالم لا
علاقه له بهذا القضايا يعني روسيا ليس لها
علاقه الصين
يعني اسيا باكمله افريقيا ليست مطروحه
القضايا اصلا يعني صارت القضايا المطروحه
في الدنمارك مثلا او في بلجيكا او في
ولايه امريكيه هي قضيه العالم وكان ليس
العلم لديه قضايا الا هذه وهذا طبعا نتيجه
الهيمنه الاعلاميه والثقافيه الهائله التي
يمارسها جزء صغير من العالم على البقيه
اعتقد نحن في المنطقه العربيه بحاجه الى
ان نلتفت اكثر الى ثقافات الاخرى ثقافات
الافريقيه والاسيويه وان نرى تجارب هذه
الثقافات كيف تفاعلت
بحيث يكون هناك نوع من
التفاعل مع هؤلاء ونرى ردود فعلهم ونستفيد
منها هنا دكتور تقرا قضيه انه المجتمعات
اعتادت على رجل الدين ذوي الخلفيه الشرعيه
كسور حمائي امامهم هم من يواجهون لكن
المثقفين الليبراليين والحدثين رغم وعيهم
ومعرفتهم الكبيره
وقدراتهم وحتى يعني
خبراتهم لا ينبرون لمواجهه مثل هذه
القضايا في في في خلق دفاعات لدى المجتمع
يستند عليها على الاقل هو لانهم لا يملكون
المنابر
اليوم ما عاد حتى المشايخ ما عندهم منابر
اليوم الليبرالي هم اللي عندهم مناظر ما
ادري والله
الليبراليين لديهم القدره على الكلام
لكنهم لا تسندهم قاعده شعبيه يعني هم
يظلون متهمين بالنخبويه بالعزله
ما عندهم شعبيه لانهم ما تولوا قضاء
الدفاع عن قضايا لو تولوا ذلك ربما
بعضهم طبعا معني بالقضايا واعتقد شبكات
التواصل الاجتماعي اليوم تشهد يعني تدفق
لاراء مختلفه حول هذه المسائل
لكن طبعا شبكات تواصل لا يعول عليها يعني
هي هلام الحقيقه من الكلام والحوار الذي
لا يؤثر كثيرا
اعتقد ان المؤسسات الرسميه مطالبه في كل
الدول العربيه بان تدعم
المنابر
الواعيه المنابر الناقده
وبدون هذا الحقيقه سيظل
لفئات معينه من المجتمع سلطه اكثر وسطوه
اكثر لماذا برايك المثقه في الليبرالي
الحداثي معزول شعبيه
لان واقع الثقافه ليس مهيا للاجتماع الى
اولئك يعني ما زالت الثقافه تهيمن عليها
التقاليد
والافكار يعني التي
تشكك في اي شيء حديث يعني فيها نوع من
لديهم لدى الكثيرين يعني نوع من
التخوف من الجديد بس ما يكون الا فيه هو
مثلا في اتجاهات لا لا طبعا انا لا ابرع
الليبراليين والمثقفين من
احيانا العزله او عدم المعرفه كيف تخاطب
الجمهور هذه مشكله كبرى وقديمه بالمناسبه
يعني ليست جديده يعني عنها الفلاسفه
اليونانيون في يوم من الايام انهم لم
يكونوا قادرين على التواصل مع المجتمع
ومظله المشكله الى اليوم النخب تحاول ان
تصل الى المجتمع
رجل الدين او الايمان في المسجد يخاطب
الاف الاشخاص كل يوم كل جمعه مثلا في في
المسجد ولده القدره ان يصل الى هؤلاء لكن
الخطاب الذي يقدمه هو خطاب عادي جدا لا
بشكل كافي او ليس معنيا بالتوعيه التوعيه
اقصد المجتمعيه التوعيه البيئيه التوعيه
الاقتصاديه كل انواع التوعيه هو مركز على
الوعظ وهذا هذه المشكله الرئيسيه ان اهم
المنابر في التاثير الاجتماعي
اعتقد ان اهم المنابر اللي هو منبر خطيب
الجمعه يعني يتجه في الغالب الى العمليه
الوعظيه المباشره والتقليديه يعني
التقيته بالمسيري زاملته في في جامعه
الملك سعود نعم
ورثيته في ثلاث مقالات لافته رغم ان
الاتجاهات بينكما ليست متطابقه لا ليست
متطابقه لكن هذه يعني هذا من الطبيعي ان
يحدث لانه
يعني المسيري رحمه الله
يعني جاء من خلفيه مختلفه وطبعا من جيل
مختلف يعني او اكبر مني بفارق زمني لكن
ايضا التقينا على ارضيه لماذا التقيتم في
ماذا اختلفت
التقينا طبعا
بالنقطه مهمه جدا يعني في قراءتنا
للحضارات الغربي الحضاره الغربيه يعني هو
رجل معني بالدرجه الاولى بقراءه الاخر
قراءه الحضاره الغربيه تحديدا
ولديه اشتغال قديم على هذا الموضوع
جاءه من جانب اليهود في المقام الاول لكنه
ايضا ترجم كتب تؤرخ للحضاره
وتطرح وجهه نظر ناقده لهذه الحضاره وهذا
الذي اثر في انا
فوجدت لديه اصداء لما كنت ابحث عنه الذي
هو كيف نقرا الاخر كيف نتعامل معه وانا
طبعا وهو كلان متخصصان في نفس المجال كلنا
في اتون او في عمق الحضاره الغربيه اللي
هو الادب ادبها
وادابها متصل بالفلسفه متصل بالاثرب علم
الاجتماع بعلم النفس الاخرين
فانا
وجدت لدى المسيره
مفاتيح ومفاهيم
افدت منها كثيرا في دراستي وفي محاولته
لمعرفه الاخر لكننا اختلفنا في في مدى
[موسيقى]
قبول الاخر حتى يعني انا اعتقد اكثر تقبلا
للمختلف لانني كنت مغمورا بالحداثه
الثقافيه والادبيه في مجتمعي مجتمع
السعودي
والمجتمع العربي بصفه عامه لكن مجتمع
المنطقه يعني هو من لم يكن معنيه بهذا
الجانب لا علاقه له بطبيعه الحال وليس ولم
يكن مغمورا بالادب اصلا يعني الادب كان
جانبيا بالنسبه له انا بالنسبه لي الادب
كان اساسيا
في العمق يعني في نشاطي
فهنا وجدت نفسي اختلف معه
لكن عندما اتينا الى دراسه اليهود وجدت
ايضا اننا نختلف
ونتفق يعني في امور كثيره الاتفاق في
اهميه دراسه اليهود واثرهم
وانا من الضروري للعرب بسبب وجود اسرائيل
ان من الضروري العرب ان يدرسوا
اليهود ويدرسوا اسرائيل تحديدا وكنت مهيا
لهذا من خلال الادوار سعيد يعني ادوار
سعيد كان يقول العالم العربي باكمله ليس
فيه مركز ابحاث واحد يجمعني باسرائيل مع
ان اسرائيل مليئه بالمراكز الابحاث التي
تدرس العرب يعني نحن نعتقد ان نعرف
اسرائيل
هذا الوهم الكبير وليس لدينا مركز ابحاث
واحد متخصص بالولايات المتحده الامريكيه
في العالم وهذا حقيقه ماساه انا وجدت ان
المسيري يؤصل لهذا التوجه ويعمق ويلتقي مع
سعيد على هذا المستوى هنا طبعا حاولت ان
اسير في هذا الاتجاه
والا لم نتفق في التفاصيل يعني في مدى
تاثير اليهود او الانتماء اليهودي على
الفكر هذه مساله كانت محل خلاف
ذكرت في الحلقه الماضيه
مصطلح جازل يقول حنا عجبني كثير استشراق
العربي تجاه مثقف الجزيره العربيه واتجاه
المثقف السعودي على وجه التحديد والحقيقه
يعني من حياتنا واحتكاكنا ثم شواهد كبيره
وكثيره على هذه المساله اليوم يبدو انه في
انقلاب في في مراكز الثقافه العربيه لصالح
الحاله في السعوديه وفي
دول الخليج بشكل كبير طبعا نتيجه الحاله
السياسيه والحاله الاقتصاديه لكن ايضا
الحاله الثقافيه اصبحت الرياض مركزا
ثقافيا بارزا في مقابل مراكز التي
التقليديه العربيه هل تمت التحول في هذا
الامر خاصه ان انت عشته من السبعينات
لليوم
لا التحول واضح لا شك يعني يعني لو اخذنا
الترجمه
كمجال
ضخم
للانتاج المعرفي للتفاعل مع الاخر
الترجمه كنا يوم من الايام لا نترجم شيئا
في المنطقه بعدين ظهرت مشاريع ضخمه كبيره
اجتذبت القدرات العربيه المختلفه
سواء في الكويت
يعني عالم المعرفه
والثقافه الاجنبيه طبعا الكويت الحقيقه
كانت سابقه الى هذا الاتجاه ثم ظهرت
الامارات في مشروع كلمه
المميز والرائع
ولحقنا بها نحن ايضا في السعوديه طبعا
الجوائز التي اسست
للترجمه وغير الترجمه جائزه الملك فيصل
مثلا العالميه تكون اهم جائزه عربيه على
مستوى يعني جائزه عالميه بمعنى انها تكافئ
طب مثلا او تكافئ في العلوم الطبيعيه
علماء العالم وليس فقط العالم المنطقه
العربيه
فهذا هذا الحضور
اعتقد انه غير الخارطه لحد بعيد وجعل
المنطقه الجزيره العربيه والخليج في قلب
المشهد
وان كانت يعني مساله
يعني اقناع الاخرين بالتغيير انه حدث مات
في تغيير في المركزيه نتيجه الامكانيات
الاقتصاديه لما نقول جوائز والمؤسسات
ونقول دعم ابحاث ونشر هذا له علاقه
بالواقع الاقتصادي واستقرار الدوله في
الخليج جائزه حمد بن خليفه في الترجمه
غير الى اخره لكن على صعيد المثقف واثره
وانتاجه وفاعليته
ما يؤديه من وظيفه هذا اللي يقصده نعم هذا
ايضا
حدث ومهم لكن على تفاوت طبعا بين في منطقه
المنطقه المنطقه ليست متساويه لانه كثف
السكانيه مختلفه من منطقه لاخرى بالنسبه
للسعوديه
الحركه الحراك الثقافي قديم اليس شيئا
جديدا لكنه اكتسب قديم وفعل وفاعل يعني
ومتفاعل مع الاخر يعني لم يكن معزولا يوم
من الايام لكن لا شك انه في منذ على الاقل
التسعينيات ونحن نشهد ارتفاع معدل النشر
وارتفاع معدل المساهمات
السعوديه والخليجيه في
المشهد الثقافي العربي يعني لو ذهبت الى
دور النشر العربيه اليوم
الكبيره المعروفه لوجدت نسبه عاليه من
العناوين لمؤلفين من المنطقه السعوديه
بل ان الان دور النشر تعتمد على المؤلف
السعودي الى حد كبير او الخليجي وتعتمد
على القارئ ايضا وهذا مهم جدا يعني
تقريبا المعرض الاول في نسبه المبيعات
وقراءه سعوديه قراء بالدرجه الاولى يعني
فهذه مؤشرات يعني لا نستطيع ان يعني الا
ان نركن الى مثل هذه المؤشرات في تقييم
الوضع عدد الكتب التي تنشر سنويا يعني
الان كان في يوم من الايام العدد ضئيل
يعني في الثمانينات والسبعينيات كان
متواضع الان العدد اكبر بكثير من بعض
الدول العربيه التي تعد مراكز
يعني الذي ينشر في لبنان ليس انتاجا
لبنانيا بالدرجه الاولى هو انتاج عربي
كثير منه من الخليج ومن الجزيره العربيه
فل ناخذ الجوائز العربيه عدد الكتاب
السعوديون السعوديين والخليجيين الذين
فازوا بجوائز عربيه ايضا يعني سواء بصريه
او على مستوى الوطن العربي البكر مثلا
[موسيقى]
في الخليج على كافتي مساراتنا واعمالنا
واهتماماتنا
الكثيره وكانت الصوره ملتبسه دائما هل
تعتقد اليوم انه الحاله في الخليج وصلت ان
تكون ان تعبر عن نفسها بشكل واضح وجليل لا
اقول انها مثاليه وصحيحه وسليمه او صوره
ناصعه على الاقل اصبحت صوره حقيقيه وليست
ما يقال عنك او ما او ما تصوره سواء من
قبل السينما في العربيه الثقافه العربيه
او السينما حتى الاجنبيه وصورتنا في
الخارج هل اصبحت صورتنا اليوم واضحه كما
نريد بشكل جلي بفعل العمل الثقافي
والاعلامي وكذلك السياسي وما الى ذلك ولا
ما زال لا لا هو الوضوح يظل نسبيا يعني هي
المساله يعني اعتقد انها
ازدياد مساحه
الوضوح او الوعي بما يجري
وهذا نتيجه المتغيرات اعلاميه لم تكن
موجوده في السابق يعني لدينا الان اهم
القنوات العربيه موجوده في الخليج
وشبكات التواصل الاجتماعي السعوديه رقم
واحد في تويتر مثلا باستخدام تويتر او
اليوتيوب فانت ترى صوره هنا الى حد ما
واضحه المعالم الى يعني ما هو وضوح نسبه
كما قلت لكن ايضا اود ان لا نغرق في خطاب
تهنئه ذاتيه يعني ان لا نرى
وصلنا
لا لدينا مشاكل كثيره ولدينا مساحه تحتاج
الى ان نغطيها
وان ننجز الكثير يعني لكي نلحق بالعالم
وليس فقط بالوطن العربي قصدت فقط من ناحيه
الدكتور انه على الاقل نحن اليوم نملك
تعريف انفسنا بانفسنا اه نعم نعم هذا ليس
كما قال هذا السابق ان نعرف من قبل الاخر
من قبل اعماله الثقافيه والاعلاميه
والسينمائيه والفنيه وما الى ذلك
نحن نعرف انفسنا ونساهم في تعريف
اخواننا العرب بانفسهم ايضا فندرس اعمالهم
ونقول لهم ندرس الشعر المصري مثلا والشعر
اللبناني والروايه في الجزائر والروايه
هناك رسائل دكتوراه تكتب في مناطق في
جامعات عربيه عن كتاب سعوديه كثيره انا
كتب عني عده رسائل وزملائي كتب عنهم اكثر
والروايين السعوديين محل اهتمام في المغرب
العربي بصفه عامه وفي مصر يعني اقصد انهم
اننا نسهم في توعيه الاخر بقدر مع الاخر
يساهم في توعيه في مساله تعريف التعريف
بانفسنا عبر انفسنا هل يتم الامر على نحو
صحيح مثال على نحو لا انا اسميه يعني لا
اسميه صحيح اسميه افضل من السابق بكثير
يعني لدينا دراسات
تاريخيه واجتماعيه لم تكن متوفره يعني خذ
مثلا المنجز الذي قدمه
الدكتور سعد السويد في دراسه التراث
الشعبي وهو ضيف سابق نعمله يعني
المجلدات التي انجزها فيما يسميه ثقافه
التقليديه وهذه عمل سعودي مئه بالمئه
بالمناسبه يعني كل المحررين كتاب المداخل
كلهم سعوديون
عمل مثل هذا استجلى تراث المنطقه تراث
الشعبي كله يعني لم ناتي باحد يقول لنا ما
هو هذا
مضيئه انا اشتغلت
كرئيس تحرير لموسوعه العربيه العالميه وهي
بالمناسبه اول موسوعه عربيه في المنطقه
العربيه اول موسوعه حقيقيه 30 مجلد
صدرت عام 98 وتسعه وتسعين ولم تصدر طبعات
اخرى لا للاسف هذه هذا العمل هائل اشتغلت
فيه الف مترجم الف مترجم
طبعا هي هو عمل جزء كبير منهم مترجم وجزء
منه مؤلف تاليف محلي فهذه اعمال اعتقد
نفخر بها ونقول للعالم اخوانا العرب
والعالم اننا هنا ننجز يعني مشوار النقد
الادبي
والحداثه والادب الانجليزي وهذه
الاشكاليات اليوم يعني بعد مشوار طويل من
من التخصص العلمي والتدريس والاشتغال
الثقافي به والانتاج الكبير كتابه وترجمه
هل يبدو مجديا يعني لو لو عدت
لفرصه الاختيار مره اخرى سيكون الاختيار
يعني اعتقد انني ربما ربما اتجهت الى
الجوانب الفكريه اكثر لانني الان معني بها
الدرجه الاولى
يعني الترجمه تشغل حيز من اهتماماتي لكنني
لم اعد معنيا بالادب الانجليزي بالعكس انا
انتقدت
وجود تخصصات
لاداب اوروبيه فقط يعني العالم العربي
بحاجه انه يتعرف على اداب العالم وليس فقط
الادب الانجليزي او الفرنسي او الاوروبي
يعني هذه طبعا مخلفات الاستعمار لما جاء
الاستعمار قال ادرسوا ادبنا وانشا اقسام
باللي دراسات ادبنا جميل ان ندرس الاداب
هم لكن نحتاج الى قسم لدراسه الادب الصيني
والادب الياباني والادب الهندي والاداب
العالم الافريقي الاخره فانا الان احاول
قد الامكان ان نوسع منظوري بحيث ان يعني
انفتح على ثقافات العالم طبعا اللغه
الانجليزيه هي المفتاح ما تزال طبعا
الفرنسيه تاتي بعدها
واترجم اسبوعيا بالمناسبه انا عندي يعني
صفحه اسبوعيه
مجله اليمامه اترجم شعر من جميع انحاء
العالم
محاولا ان يوسع الدائره ان لا نكون يعني
منغلقين على جزء واحد من العالم اللي هو
بريطانيا واوروبا وامريكا دكتور سعد
البازعي الناقد المفكر السعودي رشاكر
لوجودك ولحديثك ولسعه صدرك معنا في
المقابله انا جدا ممنون لكم وهي فرصه
رائعه الحقيقه ان اكون في هذا البرنامج
المميز معك استاذ علي شكرا لك الشكر ووصول
لكم وانتم مشاهدينا الكرام على طيب
المتابعه ان شاء الله الاسبوع المقبل لنا
لقاء باذن الله دمتم بخير والسلام عليكم
ورحمه الله وبركاته
[موسيقى]
ادير مهجه الصبحي صب لنا وطنا في الكؤوس
يدير الرؤوس
وزدنا من الشاذليه حتى تفيء السحابه واسفح
على قلل القوم قهوتك المره المستطابه هذه
المهجه الصبحي
ممزوجه باللظى وقلب ما وجعنا فوق جمر
الغباء
ثم هات الربابه هات الربابه
على ديمه زرقاء تكتظ بالدمى فتجلو سواد
الماء عن ساحل الظما على قمر يحمر في غره
الدجى ويحمي على الصحراء
غيثا وانجما
[موسيقى]